love your new show um uh
the end game
um
is it true that you would take your work
home with you
you're talking about the knives aren't
you
so i'm a big fat chicken just fyi like
when these people told me that they
wanted me to play a fbi agent i was like
do they like i don't know i can't fight
i don't know how to fight i can't i get
a bite you wouldn't know that
well thank you very much and so my my
door in the apartment that i'm staying
and has this like problem it doesn't
always close all the way and i know this
i know this and the first time it
happened i called the super and had him
walk through the apartment with me to
make sure nobody was you know you got to
check under the bed like where's the
murderer where's the serial killer you
know how this goes we're women we know
yes so the second time it happened i was
like
hey i am val turner i am agent val
turner whoever is in here is about to
get it right yes so i open the door and
i'm like just now i know like in the
back of my mind i know there's no serial
killer but just in case just in case
right so i got the i got two knives and
i had them and i was like what what val
turner it's a wonder i did not stab
myself and somebody found me bleeding to
death because i go through the whole
apartment you know and i'm like stabbed
and i'm like opening the doors and i'm
like and i was like and when i was all
done and realized there was no serial
killer hiding in my apartment i was like
i have to be the dumbest
because what would i have done what
would sterling do did you ever pull a
knife on him
no
oh no but he does love to scare me like
it's his favorite thing really yes and
it's horrible it's hard because he's
good at it he could win seven emmys and
he would not touch the joy of seeing the
terror on his wife's face and he'll
record it um i should die now i saw on
instagram that you were making a
cornbread uh recipe uh but there was a
missing ingredient i'm a big corn
casserole freak um so it was it white
like it was white corn meal it was white
corn not yellow
or yellow yes so there's this whole
thing in la like i can't find the white
cornmeal because in la most people use
yellow cornmeal for like the tortillas
and all of the different you know the
tamales and stuff like that you don't
you usually use white cornmeal so i was
on this hunt
during you know pandemic and it was like
why am i in these streets trying to find
some and i was like yellow cornmeal will
be fine so now i had this yellow
dressing and my whole family like it was
like why are you trying to poison your
children
no one's gonna survive thanksgiving
because ryan has the nasty yellow
dressing
[Music]